time's up for another monstrous
hypocrite New York's Attorney General
Eric Schneiderman a prominent adversary
of President Trump and a champion of
women in the me2 movement resigning last
night after allegations of physical
abuse came from four women hey asshole
the me2 movement doesn't mean you see
horrible abuse and say yes I'll do that
me too Snyderman a powerful anti Trump
Democrat stepped down hours after the
news broke so obviously I was limbering
up for my partisan victory laughs when
something I saw on Fox slowed my roll
this is typical all these men these
liberal men clothed themselves in the
cloak of a feminism well it's not just
Democrats I mean we're oh I mean this
this good it's cuts across party lines
what she's right it's not a
Democrat problem or a Republican problem
the problem lies with men this is a real
crisis with real consequences
specifically all of a sudden men are
facing consequences guys we need to talk
men this up we men have a great thing
going here we have all the good stuff
the corner office the bigger salaries
the comfortable shoes that don't turn
our feet into ground beef after we walk
one city block I mean no one's arguing
that we don't deserve all of that we do
but now like Schneiderman
Weinstein and in seven more years are
Kelly
I put in all that at risk men I'm not
saying that you can't break the rules we
get away with so much financial crimes
matt damon movies hell you can blow up a
coal mine go to jail for a year and
still win a Senate primary in West
Virginia
maybe tune in tomorrow but the one thing
you cannot do men is abuse women yes
guess what it's easy it's super easy
it's simple write it on your hand put
that hand in one of your many pockets
and leave it there otherwise one day
society might say you know we're sick of
this and take our Sperry top-siders
and our corner offices and give it all
to a woman just because she's alarmingly
competent and not a predator
scary days indeed the fight continues
[Music]